[Music]
Who am I explained to me who I am what
does it mean to make the journey within
oneself
[Music]
now you ask me what is me you ask for an
explanation of Who am I when absolute
existence is alluded to people use the
word I as a matter of expression when
reality has taken form through
individuation you refer to it in
language with the word I you and I are
accidents of the essence of being like
openings in the covering of a lamp of
the
no all lights as the same weather of
spirits or bodies sometimes shining from
the mirror sometimes the lamp
you say the word I used an expression
this is meant to indicate its source in
spirit but since you've adopted reason
as your guide you do not know yourself
from your separate parts go my friend
and understand yourself well but don't
mistake swelling for the fullness of
health
this I of yours is actually above body
and soul since these two are parts of
this I the word I is not exclusively
referred to humankind that you could say
refer solely to the human spirit
travel the path that leads beyond this
universe leave this world and hide
yourself within the self from an
imaginary script writing the word
identity to eyes will appear at the
moment of vision nothing is left of the
seeker nor of the path when these eyes
are absorbed in the eye of reality
being is heaven and phenomena are a hell
your eye in between is the bodice off
the interface when this veil of identity
is lifted from before you the laws of
religion and its sect's disappear all
the religious rules are because of your
eye since the latter is tied to the
human body and spirit
when this eye of yours is no longer
remaining what place have the Kaaba
synagogue or monastery
this separate eye is like a speck in
your eye when your eye is cleared forms
reveal the essence the path of the
seeker is no more than two steps
although it does have a number of risks
the first is to transcend the outer
forms of identity the second is to
traverse this desert of existence the
one here is witnessed as one's and their
son just as the essence of numbers is
one your the comprehensiveness that is
unity itself you are the unity that has
become multiplicity the person who knows
this road has abandoned self and from
partiality made the journey to the whole
[Music]
you
[Music]